doc wird gesponsert vom toyota auris
hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrisch
[Musik]
was macht uns zu den menschen der wir
sind die erziehung martina die summe
unserer erfahrungen
adoptiert folge zu uns gegangen
und selbst jetzt setz mich in meinen
grund modems in erschüttert selbst wenn
wir unseren viele erlebnisse nicht
erinnern
so prägen sie doch unser fühlen denken
und handeln aber was genau passiert ist
dass die lage sieht und jemand denkt
ganoven das ist auch in den mobilen
menschen die adoptiert wurden kennen die
hintergründe ihres schicksals oft nicht
die meisten gelangen an einem punkt an
dem ihre fragen dringend werden werde
ich mein vater wäre ich meine mutter was
ist passiert mich so bin ich überhaupt
nach oben wer ich eigentlich bin
[Musik]
die suche nach der leiblichen mutter dem
leiblichen vater ist auch eine suche
nach sich selbst
dieser film beleuchtet das schicksal
dreier adoptierter menschen welche
dieses abenteuer warten
[Musik]
nicola pardon kam aus südkorea in die
schweiz er lebt mit seiner familie im
zürcher oberland mit dem essen verbindet
nicola das land in dem er als kleiner
junge lebte aber sonst heimat sei dort
wo seine familie lebe heimat sei für ihn
kein land in einer kartonschachtel
bewahrt nicola die erinnerungen an die
zeit in korea auf sein erstes leben auch
so top 10
das ist familie wählt die worte
minimierte militanter onkel und das bin
ich als baby
er war zwei jahre alt als seine mutter
starb unterlage stadt das sehen wir mit
dem etabliert druck problem grad ab
das war sie nicht stimmt oder nicht
kurze zeit nach dem tod der mutter
verschwand auch nicolas vater
was ist damals passiert
wo nach der wahrheit suchen
[Musik]
von den adoptiveltern lebt nur noch der
vater ein gespräch über nicolas adoption
haben die beiden lange aufgeschoben
sieben mal gut funktioniert oder ja also
ja bis große sache natürlich für mich
ist natürlich schon da einfach sie will
ich ja wie gesagt ich bin nicht
vorbereitung seitdem sind der real sich
zukommen
und ich meine man vom sind hier
natürlich für mich alles leben die lüge
oder selbst schon mal wo ich sie haben
ist für mich schon job sie aber hast du
dich erinnern am ersten tag wurde hoben
die hi ich habe doch zum eckley kann ich
doch in den kliniken haben sich doch
zwei wochen lang das hat man mir gesagt
hat ich glaub zwar schwierig aber so
angst mit dass alles für mich sehe ich
auch bei meister los kostet motor in
eigentlich nicht okay das ist für ihn
ist natürlich dass diese krise wie sie
mit dem talk show das ist schon
nicola war viereinhalb jahre alt als er
von der familie adoptiert wurde
[Musik]
es ist stellt die photonen
das ist für alle sichergestellt dass ich
nicht ich sondern das ist eine fremde
umgebung sich alles für mich neues sie
im trend er fühlte sich als überzähliges
rad am wagen
ich finde das jetzt immer einige bantu
so viele eigene kinder hat und dann
zusätzlich noch adoptieren
ich finde es an zugestellt haben was ist
eigentlich die crux sie wie so dass
jeder aktiv obwohl hier schon vier
eigentlich hinterhand nur zusätzlich von
ob tiere und was ist der klub sie
wirklichkeit eher eine graue herren eine
der muss man mal subtil des
offizierskorps wonach und life ball ab
[Musik]
ist gut gemeint das gegenteil von gut
es scheint nicola das gespräch zu spät
gesucht
das ist so wie wurzel vom einbaum weg
und tanzte mit anders kommt und sagt ich
habe schätzte
[Musik]
als ich für jede vierte
abstimmen
tipp
[Musik]
da muss mir gewohnt ab 12 uhr bevor das
estland ist eine attraktion
[Musik]
entspannen
wie kann man sie fragt sich allein
gewohnt mit nach hinten was auch immer
genau zu dem zeitpunkt ist kein honig
das ist das seebad also ziemlich okay so
lieblich leute und sie hat vor
betriebliches klar hat man am hus und
der ist marita kaiser kann sie hier
[Musik]
rebecca fankhauser lebt mit drei ihrer
vier söhne im kanton solothurn
der älteste ist bereits ausgezogen sie
ist gelernte krankenschwester und
geschieden rebecca leidet unter
allergien ein sohn unter
stoffwechselstörungen ein anderer trägt
einen herzschrittmacher
rebecca und ihre söhne sind vermutlich
von erbkrankheiten betroffen weiß es
nicht
wenn man weiß wer hat das herumkommen
auch in der besseren oder mit tango
rebecca war zweieinhalb wochen alt als
sie neue eltern bekannt sie wurde aus
der schweiz adoptiert
anja dass mami
[Musik]
dass sie adoptiert ist fand sie schon
als kleines kind heraus
[Musik]
eigentlich mit vier jahre kann in dem
buch das thema stammt aus den
philippinen er ist angehender
finanzbuchhalter vor zwei jahren
unternahm er eine reise zu seinen
wurzeln
sie gehen unter die haut auch
philippinen
und das tat um und ich bin lieblich
familienschmuck sehr wenn ich mal
verewigt seit wien zum inneren
verarbeitung gehört dass ich das mache
[Applaus]
überwältigt von der herzlichkeit seiner
familie kam allmählich zur überzeugung
dass sein wirklicher platz hier auf den
philippinen sei und nicht in der schweiz
[Musik]
und ich denke ich mir alles klar wurde
ich ja gar nicht mehr groß fragen
stellen und ich sage dass das jetzt so
viel ausgelöst und und habe mich um karl
das ist eigentlich die komplette familie
mit
ältere der brüder und richter und lieber
der verlorene sohn der heimkehrte für
seine adoptivfamilie im kanton aargau
dies alles andere als einfach
[Musik]
e-mails geschrieben hat und es ist alles
rosarot sie und eigentlich zu mir über
muss ich alles besser wird und als dumm
da das hat mich schon auf die
geschützten tieren wirklich angst
entfernt sagt wilms mäßig weiß also wie
ich habe gespürt dass er die zehn neuen
familie und mir ein terrorist spielen
also unbeschreibliches gefühl und sich
neue methode als geschenk von das machen
ihr habt bei der zwei familie
das kann man nichts wissen
denn steuern und so die mutter
wollt ihr anspruch erhebt oder als sie
hätten ja geboren wo sein daraus gegeben
dass das ist ja eigentlich die richtige
oder so aber ich denke dass ich sicher
das ist sicher ein stück versucht mit
das möchte also
familie und freundin möchte die an einem
für ihn wichtigen ereignis teilhaben
lassen
erstmals kommt einer seiner brüder in
die schweiz
die hat ihn eingeladen seine mutter
sieht darin keinen speziellen besuchen
hätte ich eigentlich all die jahre keine
rolle gespielt
[Musik]
ammann so heißt der ältere bruder die
familie kennt die nur von den fotos
[Musik]
meine frau kommt aus hannover ist
kritisch und da ist mir wichtig sie das
hat mich am kopf dass er wohl nicht mit
wem ich es ist wie im kühlschrank
[Musik]
hallo roman ist eine bekannte von nicola
die koreanisch spricht er benötigt ihre
hilfe der besuch bei seinem adoptivvater
machte ihm klar dass er nicht endlos
zeit hat um wichtige fragen zu klären
nikola hat beschlossen nach korea zu
fahren er hat die telefonnummer seiner
großmutter ausfindig gemacht hallo cain
ist der großmutter ausrichten dass
nikola sie gerne besuchen würde die
sonne auf ihn warten
ich liebe dich ein bild wie aus einem
anderen leben ergo alias nicola mit
seiner großmutter bei ihr lebte der
junge nach dem tod seiner mutter und dem
verschwinden des vaters
[Musik]
extrem gehörtes und glücklich
das glück währte nur kurz der tag an dem
eine genfer zeitung über die 1.000 der
adoption berichtete war der tag an dem
nicolas großmutter in korea ihren enkel
zum flughafen brachte hat sie mir gesagt
dass ich so mit der frau außerdem will
sie unbedingt schnell setzte und da bin
ich in meiner cousine hof wo ganz viel
koreanische kindern
das war ganz genau im bus sind auch
hinter brüderle
und ich kann nur meine großmutter den
obersee vom balkon aus wie sie winkt und
ja das ist letzte bild
[Musik]
wie lange dauert es bis kinder tränen
trocknen rebecca begann erst mit 45
ihrer mutter zu suchen
vorher habe sie immer andere baustellen
im leben gehabt vielleicht wissen die
adoptiveltern noch irgendetwas auch der
leibliche vater und mögliche geschwister
interessieren rebecca
[Musik]
aber passiert wären nach außen erstreckt
und die hat sich als 44
das ist schon mal klar die bank welche
damals die zahlungen des vaters
ausführte hat die unterlagen vernichtet
drei monate sind vergangen seit nicola
mit seiner großmutter telefoniert hat
kurz vor seiner abreise fühlt er sich
unsicher
es ist doch fremd chemie das land also
mehr ideen sind einfach meine familie
nicht
fühle ich mich schon sicher denn ich
erhoffe mir schon dass er zurückkommt
dass er das kapitel wird kontron
abschließen
[Musik]
ich bin aus der schweiz aber in busan
geboren
ich wurde adoptiert und spreche kein
koreanisch werden das ist das los fiel
sowohl ich eigentlich aussehen wie die
koreaner bin ich keiner vor der eine ich
bin in julie zogg
das ist das was ich jetzt sehr schnell
filtern und märkten
nicolas geburtsstadt busan liegt eine
flugstunde von seoul entfernt am mir
hier verbrachte nicola fast fünf jahre
seines lebens
[Musik]
es gibt nichts das ihn an früher
erinnert
[Musik]
nikola hat sich mit einer übersetzerin
verabredet er braucht sie für das
treffen mit der großmutter
[Musik]
vielleicht kannst du von hier aus die
philippinen sehen wie weit müssen brüder
gehen um sich zu finden
[Gelächter]
meine finger frieren die lebenswege der
beiden brüder trennten sie schon bald
nachließ geburt er war das dreizehnte
kennt der familie
sie war bitter arm
stell dir vor wir waren schon zwölf
kinder
ich weiß noch was möchtest du sagen
eines tages weißt du da hat sich das
prozent
so würden jetzt ist alles gut laufen
lassen verkauft auf dem kommandoschiff
und tier wieder können uns nicht einfach
sind somit gut 180 erlaubt für das für
das papier so und so viel wird es
überleben
jetzt da ich älter werde realisiere ich
wie schwer es für eltern ist den eigenen
sohn vorzugeben
ich hatte moment erinnerung ist der mini
lth was man die richtige hand bei die
gletscher und zieht und dann das könnte
sich das ich hasse ich bewusst dass ich
sie nicht akzeptieren und dann einfach
kasse gemacht also sprich gar nicht da
und habe mir geht's gut ich bin gesund
ich als kurzlebige schweiz also wieso
soll ich seit ich sechs ist in jedem
zimmer
[Musik]
in den letzten wochen ist rebecca nicht
weitergekommen mit ihrer suche sie hat
die fachstelle für adoption um hilfe
gebeten diese ist prompt fündig geworden
dank mittel wieder drehen 80 dass sie
bereits verstorben ist und umso mich das
natürlich jetzt freudiges ereignis und
das resultat postadresse und was ihnen
fremd informationen von 1
die bisher gespannt das ist eine
aussprache
[Musik]
hajo sagte stocker
da ist es mir hand eine ihre mutter
geschrieben
während ihrer mitteilt dass sie suchen
und sie hatte dass sie sich in jedem
fall doch bei uns soll mal einer quote
relativ bald es ist aber so dass sie
leider geschrieben hat dass sie es nicht
möglich ist sie mit ihnen in kontakt
treten
es tut mir sehr leid dass ich ihn so
besser bescheid franka sie hat jetzt
wieso durch gewartet und die notiz jahre
die notizen sie das geschrieben
naja ich dass diese neben sie da sitzt
gehört das ist ja ja ja ja ja aber dann
geschieht das nicht möchte region nach
nachwuchs überhaupt schulte hat sie dort
bis jetzt noch bis ca
das ist ein nachwuchsproblem motto wenn
wir da sagt dass sie nicht möchte den
kontakt in der familie
sagen überhaupt zwischen die es jetzt
gibt überhaupt oder nicht das ist
einfach so regelt und wir wissen ja
nicht was es gab die das ist immer ganz
einfach drüber gemacht
ja ok
[Musik]
minijobs sondern dass das ist das
höchste zeit also nicht genau was ich da
jetzt
sie hat zu einer menschen hoffnung
jemals lehrer
rebecca hat von der fachstelle den
kurzen brief erhalten den ihrer mutter
geschrieben hat kurz gesagt ich wünsche
keinen kontakt keinen unterstrichen
ich lebe hier von der ahv haben wir den
computer nach web und auch kein auto und
vor drei jahren ein schlecht lief es
glimpflich abgelaufen ist mit
freundlichen grüßen an diabetes
[Musik]
in paris und der spitze
habt ihr noch
[Musik]
hinter dem haus gibt es einen hügel der
auf der karte steht doch das in der
nächste auch an die schule
[Musik]
an einem hügel liegt das haus der
großmutter die adresse ist dieselbe wie
damals als nicola dort wohnte
[Musik]
der mann so wird sich herausstellen ist
nicolas onkel großmutter dass ich das
noch erleben darf
die großmutter ist 94 jahre alt nikola
hat fotos mitgebracht die er von der
adoptionsvermittlung erhalten hatte
marco ist ein nutzer seine ältere
schwester und sie meinte sie hätten gar
keine fotos gehabt sie haben kann ich
fotos hier hat sie noch fotos von mir
war als ich klein war
es hat ihnen ja ich sag das hat ihn ja
immer willkommen
du hast auch danach eine tante euro wo
ist meine mutter sie war schon gestorben
kannst du sie fragen ob sie diese fotos
noch braucht oder ob ich das haus und
auf diese kann weil ich will dass meine
familie meine familie zeigen bis 10 kg
gh
also diese zwei kann ich behalten und
das ist wirklich interessant was nicola
beschäftigt weshalb hat in die oma
zunächst bei sich aufgenommen und dann
zwei jahre später fort gegeben sie
wollte dich eigentlich aussehen aber du
hast gesagt du möchtest nach amerika
gehen weil du hättest eine freund gehabt
der auch seine eltern sind getrennt und
der wurde auch ins ausland adoptiert und
der hätte dann die erzählt dass er in
ausland fleißig lernen wird und erfolg
haben wird und du hattest das gehört und
dann der oma gesagt dass du auch ins
ausland gehen willst sie war eigentlich
dagegen aber du hättest
das weiter so gesagt und aber sie kann
sich noch erinnern an dem tag wo sie
dich zum flug ins all zum flughafen
gebracht hatte und sie hätte so viel so
lange geweint und sie wollte wollte das
eigentlich gar nicht sie wollte dich
eigentlich gerne schicken wir kriegen ja
wo ich meine hier liegen ist ja nachher
besser oder auch eine für sie war das
einfach oder
sie hatte sich damals gewonnen ob doch
wirklich verstehst wo jetzt schweiz ist
und sie hatte nicht verstanden warum
nicht so gefreut hätte
das ist also ich habe nicht in
erinnerung dass ich mich gefreut auch
ich weiß sie sagt dir dass du hättest
vor freude gehüpft und hätte sich
gefreut aber nachher
[Musik]
wie kommt der mensch zu seinen
erinnerungen kann man ihnen trauen
[Musik]
kann die wirklichkeit eines ganzen
lebens nicht die wahrheit sein
[Musik]
in der inneren kommt die thurn und taxis
das ist dass ich glück dass ich will
dass er wird schon als hinweg verdienen
eigene ich glaube es gibt auf dem weg
wurde oder eine wurzel will das ist
schon okay
der besuch hat sich angekündigt
nicolas tante ist aus soul her geflogen
um ihn zu sehen
[Musik]
sie ist dein vater sehr ähnlich aus okay
sagt hier dass wir morgen kommen
wirklich und da haben wir genug zeit für
sie dir zu sprechen
ich bin ein bisschen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag ist nicola verschwunden
ohne dass in die familie oder das
filmteam noch einmal zu gesicht bekommt
heißt er ab
[Musik]
die woche von amandus besucht geht zu
ende wie wir ihn noch etwas zeigen
mein zimmer hier verbrachte ich meine
kinder ja sehr schön
kein vergleich zu meinem bett zum teil
trieft hier ganze fläche nehmen ist das
wohnfläche vor hinaus das ist ein
riesenunterschied und ich hatte
eigentlich ein aktuelles vor so einem
spiel nicht neidisch ich mache auch
meinen eltern keinen vorwurf ich freue
mich dass sie dieses leben hat und ich
mein ich bin glücklich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rebecca hat die ablehnung ihrer mutter
akzeptiert
es dauerte einige wochen
sie will ihr eine dankeskarte schreiben
welche die adoptions vorstelle
weiterleiten wird
[Musik]
dank kosten das dankeschön haben damit
positiv lösen
mit werner schulte gegossen wird sind
eben negativ auswirke haselhoff nick mit
der natur wirklich vorhatte und das ist
positiv jeder aktion hat
irgendwie
[Musik]
ein herzliches dankeschön dass du dich
so mein leben entschieden haben
dass die kraft und den mut hatte smith
weg zu geben
wenn ich habe ein glückliches leben vier
kindern
herzlichst der bäcker retten
[Musik]
armando fliegt heute zurück auf die
philippinen
sein besuch hat etwas verändert es muss
und man schon erkannt hat und dann war
der woche jetzt gemerkt hat dass die
zeit lief völlig bei einzelnen handelt
es reagiere das loch so ist eigentlich
aus
man thront guten freunden
[Musik]
unterwegs
ich liebe die ich sage auch mama papa
dass ich sie liebe
weil bei
[Musik]
es vergehen sechs wochen bis nicola
bereit ist über seine vorzeitige abreise
aus korea zu sprechen
auch elisa verstand zunächst nicht in
den fotos erkannten nicola eine andere
wahrheit als in den worten des onkels
und der großmutter
[Musik]
wir sehen würde ich sie will ich einfach
gemerkt haben wir sind gar nicht so
zornig eine hochzeit für ihre
wo sich aber verstanden haben ist
wirklich effektiv also ich biete einen
maxi so quasi nicht
verantwortung nicola
[Musik]
und beständig megawatt
für mich ist es natürlich schon produkte
auch sie haben also was sie nun lief
alles aufgegangen ist ich meine ja das
sind schmerzen und dann nach 42 der
vorstudie toren sowie einem platz oder
so ist sein gelegen und hätte so wie du
denkst nicola familie etc
naja ich meine großmutter hat der
eigentumswohnung nicht so dass ich meine
wer hat das schon früher ja
auch nicola war ein verlorener sohn der
nach hause zurückkehrte aber er blieb
der verlorene sohn
wir fangen in einer falschen
wirklichkeit blieb ihm nur die flucht
fragen was er keine mehr
[Musik]
was soll ich jetzt nur meego immer
wieder die antwortzeit und und die hat
ich hoffe ich das verstanden ich alles
verstanden nonverbal halte wie bilder
und ich habe verstanden was für mich
wichtig sehe ich ob man eine art und
doch geben wiederum antwortet müssen
ich mache spaß und man mit worten nicht
was ist die wahrheit nur ein tropfen
wasser im strom der zeit der sich stets
verändert oder verändert sich unsere
wahrnehmung
wer nach antworten sucht muss bereit
sein für eine reise ins ungewisse
für die rebecca und nicola ist das ende
der reise zugleich ein anfang mit den
gewonnenen erfahrungen und wahrheiten
künftig zu leben
[Musik]
doch mit toyota auris hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und fährt
trotzdem elektrisch